hello everybody and welcome to part 9 of
our NLT ke with Python tutorial video
series and this videos here or in this
video rather I'm going to be showing you
guys a little bit more about the corpora
how you can view the corporate yourself
and all that so you can view the
corporate individually online and
download individual parts of it online
but the problem is it's not really very
well navigatable whereas on your
computer if you downloaded all the
corpora like I told you to that's a lot
easier to navigate you could double
click on the stuff and actually view
what's within that file because a lot of
this stuff doesn't really it's just
really shorthand file names and until
you open up the file and look into it
you don't really actually know how that
file is even structured and if you even
cared it you know test it out so anyway
that's what we're gonna be talking about
is the corpora accessing the corpora and
also just finding it or corpus so the
first thing is we want to find the
corpus so the way that we're going to do
that is if you're on whatever machine
you're on get to the directory where NL
ck the module is installed so on Windows
that's going to see Python 30 for Lib
site packages and NLT k then what you're
going to look for is the data now if
you're on Mac or Linux I don't know
about Mac it's just like user Lib Python
or something like that
on Linux I'm not sure about Mac but you
can look it up any way you want to just
know where your packages are if you're
at this tutorial you don't know where
packages are the best thing I can tell
you is to Google where is python or
python model stored the other thing you
can do actually I'll just show you
really quick actually if you want to
find out where something is you can go
import NLT Kay and then we can just
print NLT k dot underscore underscore
file underscore underscore save and run
that and it should work yes okay so if
you're looking to find out where the
location of something is you can just do
this so
this is where the location of NLT kaise
in in it dot PI file is but basically
where's the Python stuff it's right in
here so there you go Mac users anyway
you're going to want to find yourself NL
TK and then the data right click Edit
with idle and scroll down a little bit
and this is what you're looking for
right here so if you're on Windows NL
Tek data might be in C n LT K data it
might be in your de and so on or at the
very end here it's thrown into app data
which is going to be the case for most
of you viewers on Windows it's going to
be an app data and I'll show you how to
get there in a moment for other people
it's going to be in a more legitimate
location user share NLT K data is
usually the first one but it can be in
any of these so check it and keep
looking until you find it
so once you find it you'll want to just
open it up so like I said Windows users
you'll go like this / % app data % hit
enter and then I'll take you into app
data roaming now you'll want to hand
down to n LT K data right here double
click on that and there you have your n
LT K data now your corpora is going to
be right in here so we'll double click
that and here's all the corpora that we
have and let me go ahead and zoom in a
little bit make them nice and big so we
can actually see them and here we have
just a ton of corpora to use these are
zipped up versions so actually the
corpora is basically these and these are
all zipped but for example worden that's
very pop powerful we'll talk about that
a little bit later senti or net will
also hit on that but let's say like
Shakespeare okay so here's some
Shakespeare stuff these are XML
documents you'll need notepad plus plus
most likely so this is it's like a
playwright so here you go got like all
this stuff speech speaker lying on line
so you can see the structure of this is
very different than say the structure of
let's go back one let's check out NPC
chat edit so here's some sub chat what's
not to like about ten to nineteen dalts
use not-safe-for-work chat or something
anyway um how are ya okay what what wow
this is an interesting chat I don't know
um we'll get away from this okay um all
right Nancy that next uh what else did I
want to show you I don't know we could
show Brown there's some stuff in here oh
the other thing I want to show you will
end up using it actually will test with
it is movie reviews so a lot of people
want to have something that's positive
and negative for sentiment to test
against they don't know what to do as
soon as I can find it here it is movie
reviews now we've got a positive and
negative movie reviews there's a
thousand of each so we'll be using that
in a little bit anyway it would behoove
you to go ahead and take a peek into the
corpora and see all of the stuff that's
available because it's a huge list it's
a bunch of datasets and it's some pretty
good data some pretty highly valuable
data I'd say now we've already kind of
covered it in the past but generally to
access that data in some fashion what
you're going to do is just do from NLT
que corpus you're going to import the
specific corpus so let's say we want
Gutenberg for the Gutenberg Bible
actually it's not just the Gutenberg
Bible I'm mistaken when I said that it's
a quite a few things actually but anyway
let's say we want the Gutenberg and
we'll import we'll get the Bible so
we're going to say our sample.txt is
equal to Gutenberg and we want the dot
raw version of you know Bible KJV KJ
text okay and then we can just print so
now that's going to be a huge mistake to
print the sample let's just tokenize it
first and then we'll print some stuff
okay so from NLT kay tokenize imports
and tokenize and then we'll just do tok
equals cent tokenize sample and then
print tok 5 to 15 okay so we can access
it this way just like we accessed I like
to stay the Union and all that kind of
stuff so anyway there's that and so
basically you can use this kind of
methodology for a lot of the corpus or
the corporate rather but not necessarily
all of them are going to work that way
so um like let's see well they can't
they will work that way actually I
misspoke again they can work that way
but the problem is like for example sent
a word net let's open up this one you
could open up the raw version of sent a
word net but the problem with that is
this is clearly a I mean it's a dot txt
but it's clearly more of a CSV something
you would treat as a table rather than
anything else so you're going to want to
handle that luckily NLT kay we're going
to be talking about Center word net here
anyways but ltk is going to kind of have
a built-in handler for this otherwise
you would load this probably into pandas
or something like that to modify the
data set but anyway
most of it is raw text so you're going
to use the raw method like I was showing
you guys here with the Bible so for
example let's actually pull this back up
let's go to the Gutenberg so ml CK data
corpora and then we go Gutenberg where
are you
berg there we are and then so you've got
all this stuff that Gutenberg has you've
got Moby Dick you've got some
Shakespeare stuff and all that and
obviously we pulled in the Bible just
because that's the first thing I think
of when I hear Gutenberg it's probably
the first thing most people think of
anyway that's it for the corpus I did I
just want to show you guys how you can
actually navigate yourself there I mean
there there you can actually look at
them yourself you can take the text
files you can use them in other things
you don't have to be using NLT Kay to
use them so that's kind of what's kind
of cool about is you can literally open
up oh this was a mistake
and no pad plus plus HR a notepad rather
you should open them with notepad plus
plus but anyway uh like this you know
look look at this man goodness so much
text and like the center word or the
Center word net is extremely useful same
thing with like the movie reviews and
stuff so really cool stuff this is
actually a big a big data set that I
think a lot of people probably just kind
of gloss over and don't really pay
attention to but there's a lot of good
stuff in there so anyways that's that
with this tutorial I just wanted to
cover real quick the corpus because I
don't want to like not cover it because
now we're going to kind of move into
more of a project with NLT Kay so didn't
want to just leave corpus behind as far
as how you can manually go in there and
look at stuff and then also get the raw
stuff but anyway that's that if you have
any questions or comments please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching things for
all the supported subscriptions and
until next time